well he was a legend Andrew and when you
look at the big beasts of television we
have lost one today I'm literally just
back in from Dublin and only last night
I was going around Dublin and I was
saying to my kids
there was the bank Terry Wogan worked in
and Ireland being Ireland you always end
up meeting somebody who knew somebody
who worked with somebody who's related
to somebody and a guy who said to me are
sure I worked with him in that Bank and
I worked with them and whether that was
true whether that's not it means
something to people people feed off that
sort of thing and he was a legend yes
absolutely
I mean what's interesting you talk about
that chitchat that you hear in when you
go to somewhere like Dublin I mean Terry
Wogan managed to bring that sort of
personal sense to all his broadcasting
didn't he yeah yeah but the other thing
Andrea's don't underestimate it he made
what was quite difficult to some people
seem very very easy and in truth it was
easy to him he had an economy off effort
with most things and let's say that
because he's a man after my own heart he
he didn't like to push himself too hard
but I think he worked harder than he let
people as we would say Ireland let on
that that he was and he had a very very
good insight into programming and he
understand he had very serious views
about things and he came across as quite
whimsical but he did know the business
inside-out I remember talking to him
about some gripe I had and it was about
lack of promotion on a certain program
and he said to me take that as a
compliment I said why's that Terry and
he said because he said promotion is in
inverse proportion to Talent he said the
more they have to promote something the
less talented the person is who's
involved in it or the less good the
program as he said so take that as a
compliment from that point of view it a
good insight he had lots and lots of
views about things he was a man who was
equally at home on television as he was
on radio and in terms of radio he had
one of those legendary voices just that
was it I mean that voice just meant so
much
to so many people waking up in the
morning Anna shoots a Andrew and when he
retired an avid viewer of Sky News
sunrise he watched us every single
morning and he would often comment to me
about what we were doing on the program
or talked about you know Jackie Bell
trial doing the sport and whoever else
was beside me that morning what guests
we had on so he was a viewer and you
know we have lost and I have lost not
only a very nice friend a legendary
broadcaster today but a viewer of our
sunrise program on Sky News he had a
good attitude didn't heed towards his
work he was fiercely astute I think I
mean that that easy manner hid quite a
sharp brain but also I'm told he who's
someone who kept his home life very
secure and away from the world of
entertainment and publicity lovely
family I mean obviously I've been lucky
enough to be in a song visitors home he
was a great entertainer he loved giving
Selecter small dinner parties and having
friends Ronny was very influential I
mean he knew everybody and I'm talking
about people in authority really hire
people in the world of of politics and
you know diplomats that sort of thing a
very good entertainer and he he liked
being an entertainer he was Lord of his
manner beautifully tight-knit family his
sons and daughters and his lovely wife
Helen who and they will be absolutely
devastated by all of this he worked hard
he ruled his luck he enjoyed the money
that he made and a very smart
businessman as well I mean outside of
television he didn't just rely on
television he had other interests which
stood by him very very well but you knew
when you went to his home that was very
much as home and it was it was a very
nice thing to be invited inside that to
see the private side as opposed to the
public side the skill of radio I've told
Ayman perhaps more so than TV is that
ability to make everyone who's listening
to you think that they're the only one
that you're actually talking to and so
Terry was always proud of this idea I've
only got one listener he used to say
didn't he because there was only one
person as far as he was concerned
listening it was each and every one
person around the country on radio to
it was it was just a beautiful way of
doing things a base of plastic way of
doing things and so he took something
very complicated and made it seem very
easily so it was like waking up with a
lovely warm frothy coffee or something
his voice was as smooth as that Amy good
to talk to you thanks for joining us
this afternoon here on Sky News Eamonn